le passé moi je vais j'ai rentré pour le
super g mardi 25 à 35 avant tout instant
pardon c'est que c'est mon papa bien oui
excuse moi papa du soleil ça non mais
est ce que vous aimez les enfants mais
non mais parce que ça c'est mon
téléphone s'est battu pour garder un
oeil juste en arrière suis là c'est pas
le mien c'est celui-là le fait religieux
qui est illégal je ne te plaît le nom je
dégage passé mon téléphone criait c'est
mon téléphone c'est moi qui composent
ces mois qui appelle christ mon prénom
je m'appelle pascal moi je connais pas
tout je veux tu m'as laisse c'est
l'espèce
je vois parle plus bah quoi vraiment
faire chipe la tâche est plus basse
ainsi attaqué
sous téléphones ces propos la santé
parlait à moncton donc à mon coach et
mon amour des verts accrochés rapidement
je vais totale et rapide à 5 minutes non
mais vous avez vraiment différente
autour de la femme ou rip mj cela en
arrière il faut tourner la tête
et que cet effet mais quelqu'un qui
m'énerve c'est que c'était là chez moi
monsieur mais je ne tiens pas non plus
je valais l'invité du jt du jerk des
trois mots cellulaire mais c'est pas
cellulaire et cellulaire tu dois venir
sur un téléphone je lui ai téléphoné
c'est super important charte en prend un
rendez vous mais je m'en fous moi qu'est
ce qui unit sa voix je m'en fous c'est
mon téléphone pourquoi tu prends mon
téléphone aux peines de france à la
marque dégagent les serrages à la fois
témoin
oculaire ou d'argent non non j'ai de 7,7
sur mon téléphone allô allô c'est sûr
c'est sa foi ne s'est pas que j'avais
pas mon style votre jet privé prêt à
leur donner un téléphone et son savoir
sans demander aux gens comme ça mais oui
normalement c'est comme ça que ça se
passe on met 25 soufi c'est tout on
avait comme une question peut apprendre
à cracher tout cissé ben voilà raccroche
bon excuse moi oui j'arrive ok je vais
raccrocher la à la bonne heure bye bye
un bijou quoi un buisson en plus mais
vous êtes malade bah oui au waf et
surtout je sais quoi dans politis mon
fils jaden pour andré tranche mais on
souhaiterait faire monter les cours mais
je crois bien mais c'est mon téléphone
mon téléphone ça moi c'est beaucoup
moi c'est moi nous devons avouer qu
votre téléphone à bourg ans à la fin
[Applaudissements]
iron
ok mon amour ou gta
iv
le hockey en cinq minutes
ayo
tu m'a même pas laissé ton numéro
[Musique]